gaming certainly isn't a cheap hobby
unless you're prepared to get dirty
while scratching at the bottom of the
Bargain Bin but fortunately there are
plenty of games that'll appeal to anyone
who has to juggle a tight budget the
current landscape of video games is
overflowing with free to play titles
gaming experiences that offer a sizable
portion of content while tempting you to
drop some cash on extra content such as
season passes or some dazzling armor in
the online store but if you manage to
avoid the spending Temptations there's
still a lot of fun to be had so here's
our list of the best free PC games to
play in 2022
Apex Legends Apex Legends continues to
be one of the most fun hero Shooters out
there the game dials up the appeal with
familiar action that was honed to near
perfection in respawn's Titanfall series
and mixes it up with an Eclectic cast of
characters the Brilliance of Apex
Legends lies in just how easy it is to
jump into while also offering a ton of
strategic opportunities for seasoned
players player interaction is
beautifully simple thanks to the Ping
system and the game looks like a stunner
and respawns focus on providing quality
over quantity updates has made this
title feel like a true evolution of the
ideas that its predecessors introduced
to the market
Call of Duty Warzone 2 2 years after
Call of Duty Warzone heralded the
dominating franchise's step into the
Battle Royale genre its sequel gives us
new modes and a new map where the
original war zone felt like a greatest
hits compilation of past Call of Duty
games Warzone 2 takes those ideas and
refines them as well as gives you a new
DMZ mode a Luton extract sandbox mode
which has you fight hordes of NPCs and
attempt to infiltrate strongholds with
teammates however since Warzone 2 is new
there's still some refining to be done
with connection issues still a problem
for some however if you're willing to
overlook its current rough edges Warzone
2 promises to be a fun time
[Music]
multiverses it was about time that
someone tried to take on the Undisputed
King that is Super Smash Brothers and
while multiverses doesn't surpass it it
certainly gives it a run for its money
mostly because it doesn't cost you any
multiverses manages to be a clever spin
on Smash Brothers clearly taking from
that game but having just enough Unique
Mechanics to feel its own not only that
but its stable of characters is almost
as unique as Smash Brothers so if you
ever wanted to see Arya Stark take on
Velma because let's face it who hasn't
then you are in luck it may be a little
Eerie when you have real life people
like LeBron James Take On The Iron Giant
but it's still fun through and through
and the attention to detail in the world
designs and character voiceover is a
treat that even Smash Brothers doesn't
fully capitalize on
Marvel snap while some may look at
Marvel snap and be forgiven for thinking
it's a quick cash grab with the Marvel
license you'd be missing out on one of
the most compelling card games out there
right now each round has you managing
your energy to play cards with high
power levels and abilities offering a
large diversity of options and ways to
win it's also a rather quick game
meaning you'll easily find yourself
playing several rounds without realizing
where the time is gone it almost like it
was snapped Away by Thanos
sorry had had to do it even without the
Marvel paint on it though it's a truly
refined experience and one that you can
play without having to dip into paying
to win add in your favorite superheroes
and villains to the mix and you've got
yourself a classic
OverWatch 2 OverWatch 2 made the
controversial decision to take the
series free to play and that certainly
has come with its caveats the
monetization and grind in the game is
definitely noticeable especially
compared to the original game yet if you
can Overlook or ignore these elements
the base of what makes OverWatch great
is still here all of your favorite and
new heroes are included and this
team-based shooter still feels slick and
refined to play every character feels
unique in how to play them and they also
still have an amazing personality behind
each one while certainly OverWatch 2
didn't reinvent the wheel and its
cynical corporate underpinnings are
noticeable it still doesn't take away
from the excellent experience that's
there
bleakshore let's take a quick break from
the multiplayer free-to-play games and
highlight a more disturbing and unique
single player experience Lakeshore is a
PS1 graphic style indie horror game that
uses the low poly models and look to
creepy effect in the game you find
yourself looking for a woman named Orla
on a mysterious Coastline as you explore
the strange landscape around you you'll
find yourself drawn into the disturbing
atmosphere and environments of the game
and that's even after you get over the
PlayStation 1 graphics and all that's
not even to mention it's psychological
and deep writing that you should
definitely check out especially given
that it's free on itch right now
CS go one of the oldest entries on this
list CS go has shown no signs of slowing
down even in the face of rising
competition in the Esports scene a
classic Showcase of high-speed action
and precision CS go Still Remains
relevant on the global stage and
regularly draws astonishing viewing
numbers whenever a big Tournament begins
a major influence on Esports in general
CS goes perfectly calibrated
competitiveness makes it ideal for both
casual and professional Gamers a
benchmark that few games have been
capable of reaching over the years
dauntless it's easy to take a look at
dauntless as a monster hunter clone
wearing fortnite armor but beneath the
obvious comparison there is a
surprisingly fun game with a compelling
grinding Loop like its primary
inspiration dauntless is focused on
throwing you at all manner of nasty
beasts with battle providing a rewarding
sense of progression and fashionable
gear every creature is uniquely fun to
battle and the game has plenty of
personality and the enjoyable combat
makes it easy to fall in love with this
adventure
Destiny 2 originally a premium product
that commanded a high price Bungie's
decision to move Destiny 2 towards a
live service format has been a
Monumental success for the cosmic
sandbox while each new expansion does
have a price tag and the dryer months
are kept active with season pass content
the free package available to players is
a meaty collection of story lines and
multiplayer action currently Destiny 2's
new light version gives players access
to every available Planet PVP
multiplayer Gambit and strike activities
that right there is a stacked collection
of content to dive into which shines
under Bungie's superb attention for
detail action-packed Gunplay and
improved sense of Storytelling that each
season has introduced to the game
Dota 2 the gold standard for longevity
in Esports DOTA 2's annual dominance of
the scene is an unbeatable standard that
every game aspires to DOTA 2's Legacy is
Gaming's most popular multiplayer Arena
game isn't just secure it's practically
Immortal what's truly remarkable is that
DOTA began its life as a Warcraft 3 mod
and then morphed into a title that gave
rise to a new genre in gaming an undying
slice of Excellence Dota 2 is a highly
rewarding multiplayer experience that is
bolstered by years of Polish tweaks and
expansive content
fortnite easily the biggest name in
video games today fortnite has become a
global pop culture Phenomenon with its
film and music crossovers game shaking
events and lucrative gameplay mechanics
that many other freemium titles have
emulated over the years beneath all that
though there's still an unbelievably
solid game built around the idea of
survival Scavenging and instantly
building a two-story condominium
whenever someone fires a few rounds in
your general direction a one of the kind
Masterpiece that has defined the gaming
industry since it became a global
success story fortnite offers value and
plenty of entertainment without
demanding a single cent in return
Kenshin impact when it was first
revealed most people looked at gentian
impact and regarded it as a cheap breath
of the wild clone while it's undoubtedly
influenced by one of the best Nintendo
switch games developer Miho Yo's
gorgeous open world RPG has established
itself as one of the biggest surprises
in the free to play gaming Market Lush
and epic in scale genshin impact mixes
the thrill of Discovery with the
compelling collectible Obsession of
gotcha games to create a surprisingly
generous package genshin impact has only
become better since it launched in 2021
Guild Wars 2. it's been almost a decade
since Guild Wars 2 arrived and in the
years since it has gained something more
important than just a polished gameplay
experience or a regular infusion of new
content a sizable and dedicated audience
communities are the lifeblood of free to
play games and Guild Wars 2 which wasn't
always a free-to-play game has servers
filled with thousands of players at any
given moment that makes for a game that
lives up to its MMO RPG title and with
gameplay that feels within the core
experience it's no wonder that fans are
still invested in this title
gwent gwent was a fun diversion in The
Witcher 3 but as a fully fledged
spin-off that has evolved over the years
the current product is one of the best
games built around collecting cards
building strategies and seeing how far
they'll go in actual competition easy to
learn and hard to master Gwen's
popularity boils down to a number of
factors every card looks like it was
produced during a forgotten magical era
the Renaissance and it's generous with
all the free cards that it hands out the
various Arenas to play in will also keep
you hooked for hours while CD projekt
Red announced that they'll be ending
support for the game in late 2023 it's
still well worth a look with the Netflix
TV show it's spin-off The Witcher 3
next-gen update and a remake of the
original game with a sequel on the way
there's no better time to dive deeper
into the world of our favorite fantasy
creature killing himbo
Hearthstone Heroes of Warcraft while
Marvel snap has given it stiff
competition Blizzard's Warcraft spin-off
is still a well-engineered card game
with compelling tabletop tactics
Hearthstone is a constantly evolving
Showcase of Ingenuity it also helps that
it looks like a million bucks with each
card unleashing dazzling special effects
on a living board that could only have
been designed in a blizzard lab years
later Hearthstone and its massive
library of cards Still Remains The
Pinnacle of the genre and a major
influence on the world around it
League of Legends every King has a rival
and for years now DOTA 2's position as
one of the biggest giants in the MOBA
landscape has been threatened by League
of Legends while the riot games
developed title hasn't committed any
regicide just yet it has come close to
you surfing DOTA 2's throne and in
recent years is pop culture footprint
has begun to Eclipse its main
competition outside of that slugging
match though League of Legends is still
a Titan that provides excellent
entertainment to the beat of its own
drum as well as some of the finest
Esports competition on the planet plus
if you do get drawn into its world you
can also dive into the excellent series
Arcane on Netflix
Path of Exile even with a sequel on the
horizon grinding gear games original
stab at old school RPG adventuring still
stands as a brilliant and compelling
game of isometric dungeon crawling while
it had no shortage of bugs when it first
arrived Path of Exile in its current
state is a more mature and focused
Venture into Dark Fantasy though it
still has some lingering issues its
content has been a thrill and expansions
have grown its free to play World
substantially
PlanetSide 2. PlanetSide 2 has always
felt different to other games on the
market due to its colder nature more
obscured systems and brutal opinion on
how fragile each player should be when
they spawn into an area but look past
these factors and you'll find a game
that has been beloved by its audience
since 2012 for providing unique gameplay
moments within its world it's still one
of the only PVP Shooters with three
factions fighting at once fresh content
such as Chimera and Javelin updates have
kept players engaged and when you first
hop in it won't be uncommon to see
hundreds of people going to war against
each other
Smite how do you create a distinct
identity in a genre that has no shortage
of competitors vying for control of
audiences eyeballs by creating a MOBA
game that's all about seeing which
fictional deities can rise to the top of
the scrap Heap Smite doesn't stray too
far away from the formula pioneered by
games such as Dota 2 and League of
Legends but it still stands tall with
its constant updates and
attention-grabbing character
collaborations
Team Fortress 2 14 years after it was
first released Team Fortress 2 functions
like a old pair of sweatpants in the
gaming landscape faded when compared to
its Glory Days but undeniably
comfortable to slip into when you're in
the mood for an uncomplicated session of
Team Deathmatch thousands of players
still play the game regularly and even
though it may have a persistent problem
with Spam toting bots on its servers
valves wacky FPS is still a certified
classic that's freely available whenever
you're in the mood for old-fashioned fun
or you know looking for your sweatpants
[Music]
rocket League rocket league is motorized
chaos incarnate this soccer style arcade
game is still one of the most fluid and
hectic games to play out there and no
matter your skill level you're bound to
have a hugely fun time shooting around
the arena with your vehicle trying to
knock a giant soccer ball into an
enemy's goal not only that the game
still receives fantastic support
including its recently announced Lo-Fi
girl DLC so hop into some of its chill
beats yo okay yeah I've regretted
regretted that as soon as I said it
valorent there's a lot of stiff
competition in the character-based FPS
space but Valerian still manages to
stand out from the pack Riot game series
takes inspiration from Counter-Strike
with ITS Tactical based gameplay but
manages to make it its own by layering
in unique hero shooter mechanics to the
world if you love tactical Shooters but
want the fun vibe of Apex Legends or
OverWatch then valorent is perfect for
you
[Music]
Warframe it may look like Destiny if
David Cronenberg designed it but
Warframe is still one of the best free
games on the market today a unique blend
of action exploration and meat grinder
enemy encounters developer digital
extremes has constantly evolved the
world of Warframe while adding content
that fans have asked for creating a lean
and meaningful experience in the process
it has starships and glorious gear to
equip chunky weapons and lethal blades
to collect while interacting with a
dedicated community of fans it should be
stated that Warframe is a bit
overwhelming at the start but if you
stick with it you'll find a highly
satisfying Loop
and those are our picks for the best
games to play on PC if your wallet is
feeling a bit light after buying gifts
this year yet if you're feeling like a
bit more expensive options are on the
table don't forget to subscribe to
Gamespot to see if some of our other
best of lists as we wrap out 2022.
[Music]